بينما ينتظر ترامب الاحكام القانونيه التي
قد تصدر بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه لا يبدو
ان منافسه المتوقع جو بايدن في وضع افضل
ارفعوا ايديكم عن اسرتي بهذه الجمله عبر
بايضا عن رفضه سماع اي نصائح سياسيه من
فريقه السياسي حول الحد من ظهور ابنه هنتر
بايدن امام العامه بعد اقرار الاخير
بارتكاب ثلاثهماء فيدراليه موجهه اليه
بحسب ما نقلت ام بي سي عن مصادر في
الاداره الامريكيه مع كل ازمه جديده
لساكني البيت الابيض الحليب السابق يستفيد
كل مرشح الرئاسيا اخر المرشحه الرئاسيه
النكهه لطالبه الكونغرس بالبدء في
اجراءاته عزل الرئيس الامريكي
تصريحاته نكهه لتتزامن مع تحقيق لجمهوري
الكونجرس حول تدخل السلطه في قضيه نجل
الرئيس الامريكي هيلي استغلت الفوضى التي
يعيشها له ضربه انتخابيه والاخر اتهمته
بالود والضعف امام الصعود الصيني هي اوسو
كما اظهر ضعفا معنويا خلال سعيه المتحمس
لصداقه الرئيس التشي ترامب هان الحزب
الشيوعي بعيده السبعين لاحتلاله الصين هذا
الفعل ارسل رساله خاطئه للعالم الشيوعيه
الصينيه يجب ان تدان لا ان نهنئها
ازمه الرئيس الامريكي ونجله يقف وراءها
شخص واحد
المشرف على مع التحقيقات الجنائيه في
مصلحه الضرائب هو الذي اشار في تحقيقاته
الى ان مسؤوليه وزاره العدل ابطا واوقفوا
التحقيق مع هنتر بايدن وازال اخطر الادله
على الجرائم الضريبيه المزعومه
لم يكتفي بذلك وامام لجنه من الكونجرس
اقواله هي التي سمحت للجنه للجنه الرقابيه
في الكونجرس باتهام عائله بايدن وشركائهم
للحصول على ما لا يقل عن عشره ملايين
دولار من شركات يديرها صينيون ورومانيون
من خلال صفقات هنتر وفقا للسجلات اربع
بنوك منفصله من كيانات وشركات اجنبيه
اثناء فتره توليه منصب النائب الرئيس لكن
الطرفين بايضا وترامب يشتركان في رقم
تاريخي سلبي استطلاع راي اظهر ان
الامريكيين يكرهون المرشحين الرئاسيين
اكثر من اي وقت مضى ولا يريد ايا منهما
للرئاسه
ون من معضله الاختيار بين الرئيس الحالي
جوزيف بايدن والرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
السبب هو ان 48% من الامريكيين لا
يستسيغون بيضا فيما 56 في المئه من
الامريكيين لا يستسيغون ترامب احد الاسباب
هو كبر السن لدى المرشحين الرئيس الحالي
والرئيس السابق
بالاضافه الى ذلك تشير استطاعات الراي الى
ان الفارق بين المنافسين هو اربعه في
المئه وهذا لا يحسب كثيرا بل يعتبر انه
تعادل سلبي بين بايدن
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات